hi i'm mark and i want to talk to you
about how you can streamline processes
and simplify your work using google
workspace and app sheet
software has made our day-to-day lives
easier it gives us
immediate access to any information we
need food delivered to our doorsteps
navigation tools to get us anywhere and
much more
but for many we have yet to see these
types of benefits at work oftentimes
people are still tracking data with pen
and paper
desktop computers and archaic disparate
software programs
that make it difficult to collaborate
and get things done
that's why we've built google workspace
and app sheet with the two platforms you
have everything you need to get anything
done
all in one place first we have google
workspace
google workspace helps you get more done
at work and at home
with communication and collaboration
tools known and loved by billions of
users
thoughtfully connected together over
time organizations start to develop
processes
think of these as established steps or
tasks that you regularly perform as part
of your role
it could be sharing reports managing
support tickets tracking potential
candidates or holding daily standups
with appsheet you can digitize and
streamline these processes
by combining them in an intuitive app
with built-in automations
take karina for example karina is a
floor manager at a production company
three times a day karina submits an
inspection report detailing throughput
levels
quality results and near-misses
traditionally this process would take
karina 30 minutes to complete
she'd have to run the inspection and
write it down with pen and paper
copy that information into a spreadsheet
aggregate that data and then
copy it into an email and send the
results utilizing google workspace
karina can reduce this process in half
she runs the inspection on her mobile
device using forms
opens up sheets and then copies the data
from there into an email and then emails
her report
this works great especially if karina
only had to run an inspection like this
once a month but since she's doing it
three times a day
she decides to streamline the process
even more by creating an app sheet app
now all she has to do is run the
inspection using an app sheet app form
and save the information
as soon as she selects save the app
updates her google sheet with the new
information
and automatically emails the results to
management using a pre-formatted email
template that karina created in docs
using app sheet and google workspace for
her inspection corrine is able to save
20 minutes every inspection
which is 1 hour a day and 20 hours a
month
so how do you go about creating an app
sheet app well
first set up your data be sure to choose
data that is organized with column
headers and then rows of data underneath
then if you're in sheets you can click
on tools app sheet
create an app and then app sheet will
begin reading your data and setting up
your app
here appsheet has noticed that we have
location data so if we look at the live
preview
we see that it has already set up a map
view that pinpoints different locations
in our data
from here we can change our data update
the user interface
and set up actions in workflow so that
our app runs the way we want it
all without writing a single line of
code google workspace and app sheet give
the people who are closest to the
business challenges
the tools that they need to create
tailored digital solutions
by leveraging the two platforms you can
work faster smarter and more
collaboratively than ever before
to learn more and to start using google
workspace and app sheet click on the
link below
you